[Music]
hello I'm Anthony absent I'm an acting
coach I've been doing it for Wow over 30
years today we're gonna be working with
a few non actors we're gonna give them
emotional result pressure we've created
one line I'm sorry I didn't mean to get
so emotional which is pretty clearly a
demand that you get emotional just to
make it even more diabolical we're gonna
ask them to first try to produce that
emotional result without any help from
me
red leather yellow leather red leather
yellow leather red leather yellow
leather I'm sorry
I didn't mean to get so emotional I'm
sorry I didn't mean to get so emotional
[Music]
I'm sorry
I didn't mean to get so emotional really
I really I really I really didn't mean
to get that emotional
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is so awkward so who's the most
important person in your life you don't
even have to say who it is
okay I'm from New York City so like
paying bills is a big thing for me just
being able to pay my rent in my bills up
I guess that'd be really sad if I
couldn't do that would you tell me a
little bit about your mom my mother is a
teacher or was a teacher she's a retired
teacher now do you love him yes as a kid
the idea of having to give the love of a
dog away is just really sad
so could you picture them over here
somewhere and could you just very softly
say to them I love you I love you I love
you mom
did you ever have a dog I did what was
his name his name was dude what kind of
dog he was a little Corgi Pembroke Welsh
Corgi ate nothing but cheeseburgers and
chicken nuggets
what happened him and the parents had to
put him down while I was working at a
music festival what would be the
scariest thing about being homeless I'd
be afraid of getting beaten up or
getting taken advantage of by people on
the street I'd like you to picture a
really scary guy
cuz who's looking at you do you worry
about them yes
would you just worry about them for a
moment please
is intense and he's coming closer to you
and he's a big huge scary guy dude I
miss you I'm sorry I couldn't be there
for you and that I was so close but that
yeah that he had to pass without me
I'm sorry that your last years you
didn't get to see much of me
but I love you what could happen to them
that you worry about there they are in
the coffin
and would you just very softly say
goodbye
goodbye I love you
say the line I'm sorry I didn't mean to
get so much
I'm sorry anything it's so emotional I'm
sorry I mean to get emotional
I'm sorry I didn't mean to get so
emotional I'm sorry I didn't mean to get
so emotional you started to believe a
little bit
remember no bad juju it really took me
back to this sensational place like
feeling the weight of his paws and like
building how hollow his belly felt that
it really kind of allowed me to connect
with that moment I've learned touching
my feelings right now just thoughts of
like different images different smells I
really felt like like helpless yeah with
no family no friends and that is
completely the opposite of everything
that I am
[Music]